[Music]
and new now at 11 progress being made at
the Flamingo Arroyo Trail right near di
in Pecos McLeod after the county
installed more fencing to deter homeless
encampments but those who live in nearby
neighborhoods aren't too sure it's going
to bring lasting results eight news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough takes a
closer look
take a look at this new barrier fencing
put up by the county in hopes of
deterring the homeless from camping out
here and those who work and live in the
area pleased with the addition but doubt
that it'll help matters being homeless
is rough out here and everybody
I know everybody's tired of them tired
of us Patrick Burns was homeless for 10
years he's been off the street now for
three months but is still very much
involved in that Community I'd end up
living right next to the wash for the
majority of me being homeless a new
barrier fence has been installed near
the wash and Flamingo Arroyo Trail to
stop the homeless from setting up camp
and Patrick who now works at the Epic
e-bike Adventures nearby says if it
weren't for the owner giving him work
he'd still be out there having those
spots like we did keeps us from being on
the sidewalk in front of your house or
at the park where your kids play parent
Brittany mossett lives right around the
corner and is pleased to see the new
fencing but says she doesn't feel like
it's going to make a lasting impression
they have to find somewhere to go at the
end of the day they don't have anywhere
to live so putting up a fence is just
stopping them from living at that
location for that moment and for her
it's less about the people and more
about the cleanliness of the
neighborhood the thing that frustrates
me is more like it's it gets dirty
there's a lot of trash and stuff that's
left behind Commission who oversees the
area of District e issuing this
statement quote we are trying to keep
the trail clear so bicyclists and
joggers can use it from Paradise to the
Wetlands Park and commissioner Sager
Bloom sharing with me his plans to open
what he calls a navigation Center which
will provide a hundred beds for those
experiencing homelessness more details
to come on that next month reporting
near the flamingo Arroyo trail near
Desert Inn Pecos McLeod Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now